j'ai effectué mon gentil raymond dont on
a fait le récap de la semaine politique
on va maintenant passer à l'année
politique puisque c'est la dernière
émission de l'année si vous deviez
résumer cette année politique très
compliqué en un mot quel serait-il
et c'est une année charnière au sens où
à la fin de l'année la donne pour le
pays n'a plus rien à voir avec le début
de l'année et en gros ce moment
charnière
c'est d'abord un moment qu'est liés au
terrorisme qui a frappé deux fois en
début d'année et en fin d'année notre
pays et la vie politique la vie
démocratique à la fin de l'année ne peut
plus être là même qu'elle était au début
d'année ok c'est une vraiment une année
charnière de ce mois le génie politique
de l'année selon vous thierry mandon
vous pouvez répondre de françois
françois hollande mais vous pouvez aussi
l'appareil peut répondre à ton avis
bertron le génie politique ou vous même
vous donner un nom ça me semble pas ça
moi j'aurais plutôt tendance à dire une
réforme je pense que c'est les nouvelles
régions
la jeune lisa sion vrille parce que
c'est un génie pourquoi c'est un génie
politique parce que c'est ça va changer
en profondeur dans la durée pas tout de
suite la vie politique française on va
être obligé de redécouvrir ou de
découvrir ce qu'est une vraie
régionalisation décentralisation du
pouvoir et un équilibre différent entre
l'état central et ceux qui gèrent le
terrain et je pense que c'est salutaire
pour notre pays
le mauvais génie politique de l'année
selon vous la boulimie c'est à dire
c'est pas un homme la rue basse et si
vous voulez un nom laurent wauquiez
c'est à dire ceux qui sont là aussi
écrit en italie mais non mais c'est pas
lui
un volume j'aime être convaincu les gens
qui se considèrent tellement
indispensable à la vie du pays qu'il
faut qu'ils soient partout voilà ça
c'est bon on n'en veut plus votre
meilleur souvenir politique de l'année
en tant que ministre c'est matière de
simplification
le programme que nous avons annoncées
avec le président de la république
autour d'un certain nombre de grands
changements permis de construire
feuilles de paye qui seront tous en
place à partir du début de l'année
prochaine
votre pire souvenir évidemment en tant
que ministre il ya eu des moments
difficiles dans cette année 2015 basse
et les attentats de ces dernières
semaines qui ont touché dramatiquement
le secteur dont je m'occupe
l'enseignement supérieur la recherche
puisque on a eu pas loin de 40 victimes
en région parisienne dans les
universités et dans dans la recherche
française ou étudier en erasmus ça a été
un moment d'une douleur extrêmement
profond est ce que vous avez eu un
regret pour cette année 2015 quelque
chose que en tant que ministre vous
auriez aimé
faire ou peut-être pour votre camp
politique
oui moi j'ai un regret c'est que quand
je m'occupais de simplification j'ai
essayé d'alerter tout le monde sur les
dysfonctionnements du rsi le régime du
rsi qui touche les indépendants j'avais
proposé un certain nombre de mesures de
simplification et qui a rendu ces
régimes plus efficace et j'ai pas été
écoutés comme je l'aurais aimé mais ça
va les modifier sinon bah il faut une
urgence absolue c'est un régime qui qui
qui fait beaucoup de mal à plein de gens
alors que dans son idée il est plutôt il
ya une bonne idée qui est perverti par
les conditions de sa mise en oeuvre
donc il ya quelques progrès qui ont été
faits mais sans succès comme le regrette
françois hollande à l'époque quand il
avait 10 sur la tva sociale par exemple
qui l'avait éliminée du jeu après son
élection en 2012 ça fait partie aussi
des regrets du quinquennat non moi j'en
ai un depuis le début du quinquennat
c'est sûr qu'on a été un peu trop
systématique sur la suppression de pas
de régime des heures supplémentaires
mais je l'avais exprimé donc ça j'ai pas
changer la vie je pense que ç'a eu
beaucoup de conséquences sur les petits
salaires voilà qu'on aurait dû protéger
un petit salaire cosy phone ou bois par
par pas par par quelque chose qui relève
de la fabrique des politiques vont
croître au maquereau on croit trop aux
grandes idées qui vont tout régler or
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche
maintenant je m'occupe de la recherche
voit des scientifiques
ils me disent attention regardez très
concrètement que chaque fois vous prenez
une décision
les conséquences concrètes que ça sur un
terrain qui sont pas toujours celles que
vous pensez que ça aura et n'hésitez pas
à corriger
au vu des résultats concrets des mesures
que vous rejetez ces mesures là vous
regardez dans l'avenir et vers 2010 2016
2016 vos souhaits pour cette année - une
gouvernance beaucoup plus ouverte
beaucoup moins pyramidal c'est à dire
que les décisions soient prises de
manière beaucoup plus concertée des
collaborer collaborative et par des
niveaux hiérarchiques très diversifiés
plutôt que par la prétention parfois que
telle ou telle à en réunissant deux ou
trois experts des choses de dire ce
qu'il est bon pour le pays
une promotion peut-être lors du prochain
remaniement on vous a vu parler là de
manière très pertinente en de toute
l'actualité politique
c'était un peu en dehors de votre
rôle de ministre mais est-ce que vous
avez des vues sur peut-être un poste un
autre poste au sein du gouvernement non
non moi j'ai aucune vue sur rien je veux
dire j'ai commencé à la simplification
maintenant je m'occupe de l'enseignement
supérieur la recherche ça c'est génial
en revanche j'ai pour ce secteur là
quelques priorités que j'aimerais bien
voir aboutir notamment en matière de
renforcement de l'autonomie de nous nous
donnons versité et de moyens nouveaux
pour la recherche notamment la recherche
fondamentale
merci beaucoup